Emile Hirsch is outside we should invite
him in I guess it's Berman yes Emile
Hirsch is in you know Emile Hirsch
Manthan I do he said I don't know him I
know the I don't know burst into the
wild though mell tons of movies he's got
a new movie out we sat next to each
other on the plane why yes that's right
how you doing but this we bring people
together Emile Hirsch and Matt Iseman
Wow plane by Road next to each other
from LA yesterday morning Jenna JetBlue
are we're now I'm revealing your travel
plans Emile yeah yeah know where to find
me we were yeah I was I slept most of
the time you did yeah I was I was passed
it was early morning do people bother
you on planes a meal like today because
cuz I was wondering when somebody who's
recognizable when you sit down on a
plane realizing that the guy next to you
no no I think usually not you think no
not really
that's good yeah have you ever sat next
to somebody that you wanted to bother
but just didn't ever India's was one
time on a plane and I was like oh man
not like she's on this plane this is
amazing and I was like well we're not
going down right I don't know we don't
know
yeah could say Cameron Diaz and others
killed and you didn't want to do this
celebrity when they go down you're like
I feel like sometimes like if people see
a celebrity on an airplane they sort of
think that automatically they're like
we're safe yeah yeah okay wait cuz they
know rationally that that you know
flying is safe and then that just for
some reason hammers at home yeah because
it would be like they're like it would
be a national and international news
story if this plane went down I'm not
this isn't happening today yeah yes
that's really unlikely I'm safe oh no
problem so you guys didn't recognize
each other on the plane no but he
wouldn't know me why not he's back in
Ninja Warrior
yeah yeah I think he watches American
Ninja Warrior I mean all American Ninja
Warrior amazing yeah same dude he's a
[ __ ] you hang out with badass right
are you a knight not a badass no wow I
am a actually I actually watched a few
episodes of American Ninja Warrior I
think on a plane did you yeah well you
know what's funny is there's a rumor
that there may be a celebrity version
going on email and people like Stephen
Amell and Jim Norton from the gym and
Sam shell
I'd be competing on it and maybe emile
hirsch dead you ought to be on celebrity
Eric majority I would totally do it I
really yeah I mean when I was training
for a lone survivor with Wahlberg yeah
like I went down to buds with Ben Foster
uh which bugs it's the basic underwater
demolition school or I know it was
created and uh and at one point we
walked out to the field seal obstacle
course and he was like have attitude and
I was like and I did some of the
obstacle course and we're all the dudes
trained and it's like that's sort of
like American dude this is what's
embarrassing way better shape then
neither so this is full circle you know
how I get motivated in the gym on my
Walkman I downloaded the audio to the
trailer for lone survivor Wow we could
be here oh yeah Peter Gabriel when you
walk in I never have synergy like
actually on my Walkman I'm listening to
it yeah I mean I'll never out of the
fight
I'll go run all the time and listen to
that dude but but like I mean I listen
no I the audio from the trailer with
like the voices gentlemen operation
rover gets a go yeah yeah how did you do
on the sea laughs - god I get alright
I'm getting fired up now play that
trailer that is the best trailer yeah
season I wanna know what he did go to
the seal obstacle course I mean they
didn't tie me or anything but I was I
did a little bit of it you know I mean I
wouldn't claim to have like kick the
seal obstacle course ask those guys are
you know yeah real bad asses who trained
real it seems hard about that is this
bit like you have to stay in your wet
clothes and sit in the sand and it's
cold yeah log it just is really uncommon
I would think so yes the courtyard and I
saw dude who was completely soaked head
to toe who was kind of waddling and I
look at this guy who's give me the tour
and I said why is he waddling like that
he goes oh well he's sort of he's sort
of shimmying around in his clothes
trying to stay as dry as possible and
have as little of the wetness touch his
skin and I'm like well that's not a lot
because he's completely soaked from head
to toe he's like yeah but every little
bit you know wow I'm worried but I get
blisters on my feet like if my feet get
wet
I get blisters like where I look
and my feet I have to have band-aids you
tell the drill instructor in Steel
school yeah yeah woman they will make
you say that dear little thing a foot
lotion that I can put on myself so that
way I can moisturize five minutes is
enough marching sir that's it how did
the seals react to you guys being there
like do they like that you're portraying
them accurately because you're actually
doing the work or were they like were
the high we hadn't dropped the film yet
and I think what you know I mean those
guys are so incredible and I think that
they just wanted to let us know as much
as they could so that we could try to do
as good a job as we could and portray
them as best as we could accurately I
feel like you do movies we have to do a
lot of work like there's a lot of
homework yeah associated with a bunch of
movies it's not like you half the time
you're not just getting a script and you
just read a lot of like like comedies
where I'm just coming in and getting
some dialogue down that's just sort of
the way that it's kind of been and but I
I personally love it I mean I like
challenges and could you - you know what
you had to learn how to skate to do
larger dog yeah yeah
and then there was sort of
mountaineering stuff for into the wild
to lose like all your weight for into
the wild yeah got got rid of the baby
fat yeah yeah then you have to go into
SEAL training well I would let that
order yeah they did its we're calling it
seal turn right right we're waiting it's
like it's the equivalent but um and then
so for this movie yeah the day Topsy of
Jane Doe yeah which I watched last night
it was really like it was good and I'll
tell you like everyone somebody comes in
with a movie I usually will I'll always
give it like 25 minutes and then get the
gist and I'll probably turn it off yeah
I didn't turn it off that's how I know
it was good I watch the entire movie
what's it about my link didn't work oh
yes it did no [ __ ] there's operator
error Ricky it's a it's a it's a scary
movie about a father and son morgue
working team that gets a mysterious body
in the night and they have to perform an
autopsy to figure out the cause of death
so it's sort of like a mystery where
yeah putting together the cause of death
and then it kind of becomes this
horrific conclusion but it's really it's
freaky and so to prepare for that I went
to the Los Angeles County morgue
which is the biggest more
under one roof in the world and I got a
tour of the morgue by the director Craig
Harvey I had to sign a ton of paperwork
so that if I got Ebola in there I would
assume our words and I went from having
never seen a dead body in my entire life
seeing hundreds and hundreds of five how
do you get permission for that is a
studio contact em or do you just go hey
look I'm an actor and I wanna I want to
come in and look i DM them on Instagram
and I'm so stupid actually I don't know
I mean I don't know I think the
producers I don't know they they just
get you in they somehow got me and they
went through the procedure that you do
but did you touch the body's organs no
you don't know how you can do that keepo
catta boys are they dead for sure on the
shore it was my jaw was like I had to
like pull it up off the floor it was
some of the images afterwards are just
I'll never forget I mean I saw like five
or six active autopsies being done and
if you've never seen an autopsy before
it is I mean you got to see it terrain
I always show up late for them tours
dubba so what were you what was the body
then that you worked at the prosthetic
uh yeah I mean we had a real actress you
cuz a lot of the movie uh they used her
this actress Owen Kelly who was
incredible and she like like was like a
method corpse I mean she wouldn't talk
to anybody just to say still lay down
and still and wouldn't yeah I mean it
was incredible and that was hard she was
on this big cold slab of marble for you
know 30 days or whatnot and that's who's
actually probably that's like a rollers
job anew and um and yeah and then we had
this like kind of this dummy the dummy
to me after I'd been in the morgue and
seeing all these people that had had
these really unfortunate ends was was
easier to deal with and I mean even now
I'll still have images of that
definitely I was thinking about that
like it as soon as I started watching
the movie like the very beginning when
you figure out that it's centered around
this kid in his dad to work at the
morgue that like just the idea of
getting to a point where you're so
desensitized that you can do that for a
living like just handle dead bodies and
it's just what you do which
just around you all the time and it's
like going to any other job yeah I mean
a lot of the workers when I went
downtown were like I mind can I get a
picture with you and they were like
throwing their arms around me and like
they gots dead or still that they're
like gear on and I was like I'm getting
like pieces of people right now yeah um
but yeah I mean I guess it's you know
there was there was a certain kind of
gloom that I think my character has in
the film there's just it's just like a
little bit of sadness and melancholy and
that was I think you know probably
because he'd been handling all those
bodies were you allowed to actually
stand there while they did the autopsy
or yeah you have to watch one of the
room no no that he's like the Kramer in
Seinfeld in the audience like yeah Shh
and open and his worker song it was like
hey man come on in here like he
literally said it like that so you got
to stand it right where they gave me a
mask and I wasn't like standing next to
him I was a few feet to the side but I
mean you see the weight I mean I saw
puck it's the morning I don't want
people to like spit take their coffees
in the car but it was pretty heavy stuff
what was it like I think I'm kind of the
chance exactly saw I saw a woman like
flee get cut open I saw I saw a guy have
his um a scalp peeled over his face with
his ears clipped on both sides so they
pulled his face all the way down then
they drilled open his skull and pulled
his brain doubt and then snapped his
brainstem tillis you could like hear
that click was like and that's how they
get the brain out Christ I don't know
that might have just been a quirk that
that one guy had no baby but but that's
like that's like so [ __ ] because then
you realize like that your brain stem
that like it the reason everything works
like it's just one guy's snap away like
it's just where you also got how unique
you're not like everything's we're
unique and we're special and like snob
just a hunk of [ __ ] body parts that
they're eventually going to cut out and
throw in the garbage yeah yeah I mean I
think the dotted up they don't wear to
garbage view of humanity but like I
think you know it's just the business we
have bodies and that sort of alright I
guess it's inside the soul yeah it's
it's it's it's the the living that's
what art gets in touch with the soul the
spark
yeah yeah well that's what I came Eric
and ninja warrior' my Nobel laureate
over here but that you want to believe
that you're special
right and that your body is somehow
associated with that but you're not
realizes snap you well in a way but
we're all like just when you're dead you
just some guys just gonna scalp you and
snap your brain dude the heroes decide I
actually looked at the director of the
morgue Craig Harvey and I think as the
brain was being pulled out he was like
there's your computer yeah okay that's
it
what are you as Craig like yeah are you
glad to be alive any like looks means
just like oh yeah it just keeps moving
he just keeps moving I mean and then
there was this like little uh like kind
of short portly Latina woman mm-hmm that
was cutting this just like half burnt
corpses ribs like but like with huge
bolt cutters and I was like this really
audible Iraq and he goes you see her
over there Craig said this I was like
yeah and he goes
she uh she used to be upstairs she was
the secretary and she heard the stories
and she she came curious she wanted to
know where the action was so she took
some classes and here she is she's one
of our best medical examiner's now and I
was like wow so it's like Craig's egret
Society right Craig sounds like a fun
dude to hang out with her in Fast Times
I just witnessed a hyphenated coffee
no I guess time so I switched to the
caffeinated call oh yeah he's the guy
did he play uh he was in one full of the
Cuckoo's Nest and he wasn't played like
his priest in today yes yeah I don't
know he has he's kind of a bit of a
ghoul but the 1985 video P has to shut
up right now huh yeah I know the guy
that stutters name yeah Wow Wow I don't
know his name either but I know exactly
we're talking about it you just Vargas
these are the hills have highly yeah oh
wow yeah yeah oh wow yes I said that
Craig well they like him got a mustache
when we're getting there
he's dead
is there anybody that like intimidates
you to work with because you've
developed I guess you must have
developed a relationship with like Sean
Penn now because you've done a couple of
things together yeah and you've you've
been in you've been directed by the guy
who directed The Exorcist like you've
gotten to work with a lot of pretty
impressive people that to me would feel
intimidated but I don't know if that's
how you approach it um I mean I
certainly have a massive amount of
respect for the people that I've worked
with and you know certainly working with
Sean was uh I mean he's a real badass
guy yeah really smart not like this
American Ninja Warrior go ahead I mean
he's just I'm going head to head with El
Chapo I mean he's just like a fearless
guy in a lot of ways yeah so I mean I
think I think the best the best world
that you can kind of operate in is that
you learn from those people and they
just try to make you better
yeah you've done some of this stuff with
with Sean though right like you guys
went to Haiti together oh yeah he set up
a kind of a charity in the operation
down there an NGO and I went down there
for 12 days and just you know did what
little I could sort of help out the
operation they had which was was pretty
sprawling they'd actually set up a um
you know kind of a base where a golf
course had been and a lot of people were
living there I have to imagine that when
you're hanging out with Sean Penn it's
hard to be apathetic you know what I
mean like it's hard to my cuz he's got
such an it like enthusiasm any any so
yeah yes so much conviction yeah what he
believes in and right and wrong and
morality and doing things for other
people and I think that that that really
rubs off on people it really does and
it's it's really refreshing being around
someone like that too because like what
you just said like they're there it's
really easy to become apathetic
especially in this world right now
you know but when you meet someone that
truly isn't and I think that that's what
drew him to want to even make into the
wild it was you know a movie about a
character who wasn't apathetic could
cared about everything and who really
wanted to help people right was the
motive of that guy to like just leaving
and not telling his family where he was
going Alexander super super train yeah
I think you know a lot of it had to do
in terms of not telling the family there
was a lot of anger towards the family
and a lot of pain and he was sort of
kind of wanting to sort of divorce
himself from his parents that was what a
lot of it really was but he also at the
same time wanted to kind of start anew
and go on this epic adventure but over
the years he was he's been sort of
dismisses you know being too hard on the
parents and like how could this loving
kid do this to his parents but the
parents the relationship with the
parents was a lot more contentious and
since the movies come out his sister
Carine McCandless wrote a book called
the wild truth where she delved a little
bit deeper into that family dynamic and
and you sort of realized a little bit
more what Chris has done and how it
wasn't quite as crazy so she points out
like yeah he wasn't just this selfish
kid who ran away yeah I mean there you
know she says there was a lot of abuse
and and things like that oh wow hey
chump and by the way back to him he's a
ballsy guy yeah the fact that he did go
into Mexico and met with Al Chappell and
like risked possibly being kidnapped I
mean that says tremendously to go to the
interview Widow yeah yeah and then when
they say that the interview partially
contributed to him being captured or
something I heard that the Mexican
government said that I mean that's sort
of like the yeah offers communication
with that woman el chapo was like he was
like into the decidable enough it's so
amazing a very texting god el chapo -
all right Hamilton yeah sort of like the
I don't know it's it's like the the
flame of Fame is just irresistible for
right these types Sean Penn was El Chapo
did he why he wanted to meet the what
the Mexican girl who he was kind of in
love with and she brought Sean Penn but
he was in love with this I think she was
a journalist or she was an actress this
was like a soap opera maybe they don't
she was yeah but he was really really
into her but isn't that it I mean but
it's right because partly because she's
a soap opera actress yeah like he's got
all this powers he's controlling
everything but he's still not like a
celebrity he's not like an actor but it
was all just shot dead tomorrow
yeah did you read his awful text to her
- El Chapo he was saying those like I
would protect you like my own eyes
like really cheesy great drug lord but
terrible dirty texture when you're doing
a movie like the autopsy of Jane Doe
like when you get the script and
everything and you're signing on like
it's a movie where if it's not filmed
correctly or if the corpses look cheesy
or whatever everything can go wrong is
that something that you pay attention to
or you just like I got it just have
faith in the director it was kind of
funny but okay so when I first got the
script there was this title page after
the official title page where it
basically said an autopsy is by its
nature graphic however this film is
intended to be more poetic and
expressionistic and not overly exploited
and then you see the movie and it is the
most graphic great-grandpa autopsies
imaginable um I don't think they gave
the director that they said that's like
the actors to get them like it's like
expressionistic yeah and it's not one of
these gory movement it's not I mean it
doesn't feel exploitative at all or
gratuitous but an autopsy is graphic
right you know there's this movie
concussion was well with Will Smith and
the first five minutes the movie is an
autopsy and you never see the corpse
like him being like on his faces he's
like and there's the brain you know and
so this movie doesn't do that at all but
um the director Andre over at all he
made this movie called troll hunter
which was on it's on Netflix if you want
to check it out it's actually really
good it's like this mockumentary about
these college kids who try to do a
report on the sky who's supposedly a
troll hunter and then it turns out he
actually is and he works for the
government he hunts down these massive
trolls across the country it's really
good so I had a lot of faith in him just
from this film because I I was like this
guy's a talented guy he's going to do
well but if a film avoids showing
something like you say in the first five
minutes where they don't show it at all
it's like that's almost gratuitous in
the other way where it's like insulting
like you know we can handle right you
know right if they're totally avoiding
all of it it's like yeah and I think in
particular with the case of the autopsy
of Jane Doe after I left that Los
Angeles County morgue I called up the
director and I said you know if the
horror that I just experienced going
into this morgue if you can capture 1/10
of that in this film like this is going
be a truly horrifying tom yeah and and
and and the whole film does take place
within the morgue like it's this sort of
it's this confined that's always amazing
yeah so when you when you can take a
movie which you always expect spectacle
and it's so intimate told the story the
acting use has to be so compelling to
drive it I can't wait to see this yeah
and I think that is one of also one of
the benefits is of having that Sherlock
Holmes detective story it's not like a
play where it's like two people being
like and then we we went over to the
thing and we're you know they're finding
the clues right you know so you're
really building it's it's a
psychological kind of intellectual
building like Quinte with like the
United mean the coroner gets involved
more than a coroner would usually get
involved no yes we're not getting Quincy
references remember Quincy 85 ah damn it
was born in 83 so he lived on a boat a
day who's a medical attendant Quincy to
me was my 9 year old neighbor when I was
a little kid growing up yeah so you did
maybe the reference isn't exact Jack
Klugman was a nine year old they were
exactly a mu it was a murder do Quincy
all day oh yeah I wouldn't I'd be lost
December 21st by the way is when the
autopsy of Jane Doe is out in limited
theaters the day before it shows up on
video and on demand and all that stuff
so that's fun right when when you can
get you know that there's that many eyes
that have access to a movie star you're
so excited about is really it it's kind
of crazy about it is so the trailer came
out online and it's not like a big movie
or anything but for whatever reason it
went like mad viral about 10 million or
more views it's crazy do you like the
fact that it's on alt which is really
unheard of for a movie like that do you
like it being on demand as well at the
same time or would you prefer it was
just in theaters I mean these days I
don't know so many people are so used to
TV shows and binge watching TV shows
that I have less of a problem with it
now than I ever had before I don't
necessarily know if I it's the most
ideal but at the same time so many
people I talk to they don't go to the
theater as much as they used to they
watch West world they watch Black Mirror
they watch all these shows so I can
think and have access
sounds like this the setting the
ambiance it would be better appreciated
in the theater I feel like stand-up when
people watch stand-up on TV they don't
get it is it's live it's magical and I
feel the same way about movies like a
movie is meant to be appreciated in the
theater no no focus taken away the big
screen I gotta tell you I and cuz
generally right like I like going to the
theater I was watching this movie on a
laptop last night like that's where the
screeners and a lot of times you lose a
lot in a movie when you're just watching
on a laptop screen but the whole time it
was like 11 o'clock at night so I just
kept like looking over my shoulder yeah
I like it and still getting freaked out
about all the visuals and everything it
really is a creepy movie and you know
these days were so used to like being
attached to our phones and and we're
used to viewing things the size of our
screens yeah that when you actually
watch like a TV now it seemed really bad
it does really weak is like oh I'll
watch stuff on my phone like I'll watch
movies on my phone I'll read books on my
phone uh-huh
so when I actually watch a TV now I'm
like wow that's way bigger than my phone
what's a movie like that you don't have
to watch it it's not like it's a special
effects driven film it's not like it's
something in a Pacific Rim that you got
to see on a giant screen right I
wouldn't necessarily recommend watching
it like alone at night though like I
actually think that would be it's really
creepy that's the best way to watch it
eat weed out I I mean I I made the
mistake of trying to nurse a couple
times alone at night at my house and all
the sudden the house would start
creaking and I'd be looking around and I
was like and I like literally stopped
rehearsing at night I was like yeah I
like being creeped out by a film it's
nice means you're feeling something is
it funny these days how many people do
you talk to these days that are like oh
yeah I don't do scary movies I go why I
gather too scary yeah there's a lot of
people at lunch I can't handle like yeah
they don't want anything upsetting
nobody wants anything upset I love being
scared pointed right yeah no I I just
want something II they want some of
emotional snowflake it sounds like a
night I used to hate nightmares now I
like a nightmare cuz you wake up and
you're like oh god I'm not in that
horrible place I'm in my bed yeah almost
to a good dream when you wake up you're
like oh I wish I were still asleep
though that was fun there's some
nightmares though that like like hot
all day that's I don't like those okay I
don't use the motion it don't know what
morg is like what is scary over that
creeps you out or makes you feel
something it's like that's such a great
thing to have pulled out of you
cuz you remind you you're reminded that
you're a human being yeah I know I have
the women I date feel creeped out
uncomfortable but no I like that man it
means if we it's like a good comedy that
makes you laugh or whatever movie that
makes you cry as if it makes you feel if
you feel nothing at the end of a movie
like okay that was a thing then what's
the use of doing it yeah I always wonder
you got into a little legal trouble last
year last summer and like I always
wonder about the industry like when that
happens do you have to go on like an
industry like apology tour so everybody
knows you're cool or do you just kind of
pick up and go I think it's it's just
about you know moving forward and being
as positive as I can you know step by
step and you know just trying to sort of
lead by my actions right so like like
yet just going forward and being like
wow I can only speak for what I'm doing
right now and notice I mean I think I
think that it's it's really important to
just do the best I can every day yeah
yeah Holly was a pretty forgiving place
if you're genuinely ready to like you
like okay I [ __ ] up but now I'm not
[ __ ] up they don't forgive a lot of
stuff at Hollywood as long as you not
continually disgust you if you're good
at what you do yeah right like a lot
yeah like if you're an artist you're
good at what you do well I think I think
the important thing too is to is to
learn from your errors yeah and correct
your actions I think that that's a
that's a really important yeah I feel
like we build we love to build people up
only to tear them down and then have
them grovel at our feet and then allow
them to come back store yeah I mean
Society though like we you know society
there there's this perverse notion if we
love seeing people stumble you know we
love seeing people be human and it's
like you know it happens to everyone
everyone makes a mistake but I think
it's I think it's really important
though that you know people take
accountability for what they do as well
yeah and you know admit that they made
mistakes well that's what you did and
you ended up doing a couple weeks in
jail right does that like when you're in
there because you go from Hollywood to
the complete opposite right like this is
that where you're like let me
reshape the way I think about things I
mean you know you could definitely call
it a wake-up call I mean it's not a
pleasant place to be in and I think I
think the important thing is that you
know if people have problems with
alcohol or drugs or their blacking out
or something like that you know those
those are things to pay attention to
those yeah those are you know that I
don't think that because I've talked to
so many people since they've had
problems and similar problems and it's
just it's something that people should
really pay attention to and be aware of
how he treated jail was there any
problems there or they kind of just keep
you separated well I think you know the
I sort of benefited from the fact that a
lot of the guys in there had a lot of
respect for the armed forces and for
lone survivor and the kind of Steel
community so yeah it day it enjoyed that
film and um I was just respectful of
people and hope that they were the same
because you whatever you like the idea
of going to jail is so scary like I'm
afraid like I'm gonna say the wrong
thing and awesome when you find out that
they're like not a fan you know okay
cool yeah all right good good
well it's also a bit of research
hopefully if that ever comes up for the
movies you want it to do yeah because
you did it instead of uh like going to
the morgue you mean yeah creepy very
creepy what's uh what are you doing next
I'm going to do a film kind of a weird
quirky comedy in Northern California uh
called an evening with Beverly luf Lynne
we're going to go shoot that but but the
next thing I have coming out is I worked
with JK Simmons on a kind of Buddy movie
called all-nighter how is he it was he's
amazing he's really funny he's a great
guy uh and the movies is pretty is
pretty Schillinger from ah yes right yes
Beverly uh Flynn that's a great name
yeah he's sort of like the protei - hey
Beverly yeah yeah he's sort of like a
kind of a magical presence where you
don't really know exactly what he does
it's like you're taking a lounge
stand-up act kind of all kind of pressed
together it's pretty great always a
comic and does all kinds of yeah so it's
but it's kind of like you don't really
know exactly what he does
they keep it a little bit bag oh it's
just an entertainer yeah yeah do you end
up like when you do these movies you end
up having relationships with people that
last or is it like like for instance
when you're working with like JK Simmons
is that somebody that you now kind of
known have connected with or these
relationships that just kind of exist on
set and then you both kind of I'm your
own thing I mean it just depends on who
it is you know what I mean sometimes you
really connect with somebody or you get
along for a particular reason
I like a John Goodman and I on Speed
Racer we got along really well and he
ended up like letting me live in his
house for like a year that's all yeah I
was like amazing it was like wow okay
and he was just you know yeah yeah he
had a house in Los Angeles and he was
like nice enough to let me stay there
for a bit and like a little bit just
turned into a friggin year why wasn't he
there well he's always working and
flying around and he's got multiple
houses he's got another one so I was
like just awesome and he would sometimes
come and we would like watch baseball
games and I was just amazing that is
amazing actor he should get nominated
for an Oscar for Cloverfield Lane yeah
he doesn't really get so good in that
movie
Janka he doesn't get credit for enough
of the stuff he doesn't realize it's
just so good and everything yeah used to
him being great in everything yeah yeah
he's amazing Andy I do you look around
the house a points going like you have
to don't forget this is John Goodman's
house it's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah
I've been around the boys going enjoy
this house cuz you're never gonna live
in it do you go through the drawers I'd
have to go through the drawers would you
have to you because of underwear I've
got a weird honor code like that I'm not
going through the drawers there's a
princess seal trading yeah retail trader
you're you're a good person that Jim on
the other hand is not a truck like this
guy I get freaked out I have actually
people doing something in my place today
like we're fixing something I get so
freaked out by beat people being in my
space like I don't like people touching
my [ __ ] I'm yeah I don't know how you
let anybody stay in your house just
going to assume they're gonna go through
all your stuff touch it you're right I
mean just take a lot of trust yeah you
let someone stay in your place sure all
right see guy look him in the eye not
you and not you yeah we cool are we good
we're cool right here hidden huh that's
hilarious well listen
everybody needs to go check out the
autopsy of Jane Doe it's as I said it's
going to be on demand and all over the
place starting December 20th I'm
assuming iTunes Amazon all over the
place and limited theater release on
December 21st it's always good to see
these movies and theaters I think
because I feel like everybody complains
that the only thing that gets played in
theaters is like superhero movies and
that nothing happens anymore
but when a movie like this comes out
limited release if people don't go see
it then there's not evidence that more
movies like this need to be shown in
theaters Yeah right
so I check that out and of course you
can follow a meal at Emile Hirsch on
Twitter thanks for hanging out me thank
you thanks for having us been fun